bonsoir il est 18 heures si vous nous
suivez en direct en ce lundi merci de
nous rejoindre pour le journal de la
rédaction de tv fil 78 journal diffusé
exceptionnellement en simultané sur
radio sensations au cours de la
prochaine heure vous allez suivre la
marche blanche qui vient de débuter
attrape une marche en mémoire de mousse
à 14 ans victime d'une fusillade au pied
de son immeuble square albert camus un
second jeune de 17 ans qui
l'accompagnait à lui était blessé à la
jambe vendredi ce sont des faits qui
sont survenus vendredi tout au long du
week-end déjà la population s'est
mobilisée plus de 400 personnes dans la
rue et de cette commune est dans le
calme et aujourd'hui lundi elles sont
près du double être réunies en tout cas
attendu sur place à trappes pour télé
filet pour radio sensations nicolas
kirilow vie de sa compagne et de
williams elle pour la technique bonsoir
nicollin dont sera un moment de
recueillement particulièrement fort qui
se déroule qui débute à trappes
aujourd'hui oui exactement un moment de
recueillement une ambiance très
solennelle ici place des brises y
attraper leur place en quelques
centaines de personnes
un invité surprise malheureusement c'est
la pluie mais de nombreuses personnes
une ambiance calme sereine
beaucoup de personnes qui encadrent avec
des maillots des gilets jaunes ici qui
disent ils une des roses blanches par
exemple beaucoup de gens ont une rose
blanche dans l'aimable ya beaucoup de
banques gardent aussi hommage à moussa
qui sont distribués ou des ou des
autocollants rentre je vous disais pas
gaston personnes toutes dotées donc que
d'une rose blanche
l'ensemble de la classe politique qui
est présente évidemment di malanda le
maire à lire à b l'élu en charge de la
jeunesse et du sport encore l'utiliser
et du 12 et du communiste sur la commune
de trappes et une autre tendance
importante forcément c'est l'agenais fin
de ce cortège pour l'instant beaucoup de
jeunes familles de moussa ou de simples
collègues de collège donc voilà pour
l'instant ambiance simple
re de recueillement et le cortège est
prêt à partir de maintenant il va partir
d'ici quelques minutes et on vous suivra
et on suivra à cette marche avec vous et
nicolas tout au long de la prochaine
heure édition spéciale sûreté les filets
sur radio sensations la population qui
se réunit donc en mémoire de moussa
également pour dénoncer la spirale de la
violence dans cette commune c'est au
collège gustave-courbet que ce jeune
moussa a été scolarisé un jeune sans
histoires apprécié de ses camarades la
rentrée ce matin après les vacances
scolaires s'est déroulée dans la
souffrance une cellule psychologique a
été mise en place
mélanie poker yolaine torres rentrée
plus que difficile ce matin pour les
élèves et les équipes pédagogiques de
l'établissement gustave courbet à
trappes
c'est dans ces murs que moussa a étudié
en tant que les détails financiers dans
les classes pour sa classe lors des
journées et pluviales et élèves qu'il y
avait donc des cellules d'écouté à leur
disposition par les infirmières
assistantes sociales les médecins
scolaires sont actuellement auprès des
enfants les plus touchés pour trouver
une minute de silence a été organisée
dans la cour de l'établissement ce matin
au moment de la récréation des dessins
et des textes ont été réalisés par ceux
qui le souhaitaient ses productions
seront remises à la famille de moussa
édition spéciale du journal aujourd'hui
sur tv fils édition consacrée à la mort
d'un adolescent à trappe victime
vraisemblablement d'un règlement de
comptes entre bandes rivales mais que
s'est il précisément passé vendredi 1er
mai dans l'après-midi le résumé des
faits 7 avec quatre nuls à taux et
william l vendredi 1er mai entre 15h15
et 15h30 une voiture surgit dans le
square albert camus attrape des
individus cagoulés sortent d'une voiture
renault et tire sur un groupe de jeunes
avec une arme auto
atik 9 mm quatorze douilles seront
retrouvées sur place moussa 14 ans est
abattu un autre jeune de 17 ans
légèrement blessé à la jambe est emmené
dans un hôpital des yvelines une
escalade de la violence alors que la
ville connaissait depuis quelques
semaines des rixes entre différents
squares trap est une est une ville qui
est plutôt qui s'est beaucoup calmé
depuis plusieurs années puisque mis à
part les événements qui a eu lieu au
mois de juillet 2013
les violences urbaines ont
considérablement baissé
mais c'est vrai que paradoxalement les
trafics de stupéfiants le cannabis entre
autres je gêne et enfin les trafiquants
n'ont aucun intérêt à ce que les
services de police vienne vienne
enquêter et et se gêner leur gêne et
gênait c'était cette économie
souterraine
la voiture des fuyards a été retrouvé
calciné à ben les enquêteurs n'écartent
aucune piste guerre de territoire x deux
bandes rivales sur fond de trafic de
stupéfiants
l'enquète s'annonce difficile et nous
repartirons dans quelques instants à
attrape où se déroule en ce moment une
marche blanche en mémoire de mousse un
marche pour dénoncer également la
violence dans cette commune bonsoir loïc
travers bonsoir à vous êtes l'un des
responsables du syndicat de police
alliance nationale secrétaire zonal
adjoint on vient d'entendre un bref
rappel des faits de ce qui s'est passé
vendredi dans cette commune aujourd'hui
où on l enquête ce n'est que le
commencement
bah tout à fait pour l'instant ce n'est
que le commencement il y avait bien
évidemment toute la phase des
constatations réalisées par la police
judiciaire de versailles
et là maintenant c'est un travail de
longue haleine
de la part de mes collègues de la pj à
la fois bien pour effectuer des
recoupements judiciaire des
rapprochements judiciaires effectuées
toutes les enquêtes de voisinage étudié
l'entourage des victimes
et puis analysées effectivement les
témoignages et voir un petit peu comment
comment tout ça s'imbriquent et essayer
d'avoir un mobile qui pourrait expliquer
cet acte tragique
là il faut repartir du tout début donc
être commence parce que tout simplement
le véhicule qui a servi qui a été
utilisée elle parlait parlait meurtrier
a été incendié ah ben ça ne facilite pas
la tâche des enquêteurs effectivement à
partir du moment où l'intégralité où une
partie des preuves ont été détruites
notamment parce que le véhicule a été
incendié
c'est une difficulté maintenant les
enquêteurs disposent de tout un tas
d'autres moyens pour effectuer
effectivement la poursuite de l' enquête
est ce qu'il ya des éléments aujourd'hui
dont on est certain on parle de ce jeune
moussa qui est décédé qui était un jeune
sans histoire sans problème également de
son ami qui était avec lui à 17 ans qui
lui a été blessé à la jambe
ce sont des victimes collatérales d'un
règlement de compte et il était mauvais
endroit au mauvais moment
ça c'est trop il faut pas le dire je
pense comme ça le but de la police
judiciaire sur sur une enquête difficile
comme celle ci c'est effectivement de ne
rien négliger
c'est à dire que toutes les pistes sont
possibles ça peut aller du conflit
personnel ça peut être des bandes
rivales ça peut être des suites d'une
bagarre
ça peut être une affaire de stupéfiants
pourquoi pas un règlement de comptes
mais personne ne peut le dire
aujourd'hui
donc l'idée bien c'est de ne surtout
rien négliger c'est surtout la bonne
base d'une enquête réussi c'est à dire
dès le départ partir d'une façon neutre
pour balayer large et ensuite se
recentrer sur ce qui semble être la
vraie raison la violence des faits un
tel acte c'est inédit sur trappe
oui c'était on peut dire que c'est
inédit sur trappe il y a eu
effectivement récemment 1
on dire des coups de fusil qui ont et
qui ont été tirés mais là on peut dire
effectivement que c'est une première
parce parce que nous à nous avons
l'utilisation d'une arme automatique
calibre 9 mm ont tirs en rafale on a une
certaine rapidité dans l'action on a un
véhicule qui est brûlé probablement une
multitude d'auteurs de par la façon dont
ça s'est passé
donc ça veut dire que là effectivement
on n'a pas de moyen de comparaison
récent d'une façon générale sur les
yvelines et sur trappe en particulier là
on a vraiment quelque chose de
particulier qui a été qui a été commis
mais c'est une escalade de la violence
parce que vous l'avez mentionné quelques
coups de feu il ya une quinzaine de
jours il ya eu également un jeune avait
blessé par un coup de couteau qui se
retrouvèrent à l'hôpital à la clinique
de trappes également il ya cette
violence qui s'est installée larvée et
qui depuis un mois comment ça a explosé
un petit peu sur cette commune l'intérêt
c'est de voir si effectivement les
différents faits que vous évoquez puisse
effectivement éventuellement être liés
les uns aux autres on sait pas
aujourd'hui donc peut-être que c'est
intéressant que l' enquête va
s'intéresser justement c'est à ces faits
là ces éléments là ensuite la vraie
problématique de trappes d'un point de
vue policier sait que c'est une dsp et 7
et d'espèces malheureusement a été créé
avec un effet un effectif constant il
n'y a pas eu de moyens supplémentaires
qui ont été mis en place et peut-être
c'est un petit peu dommage
au même titre que récemment une
communauté d'agglo d'agglomération a été
créé sur dû justement elancourt traduit
en courbes et on fait le même constat
c'est dire que les policiers n'ont pas
eu forcément plus de moyens ni financier
ni en effectif et bien pour garder le
calme dans la cité ou en tout cas dont
sur cette ville alors que trappe ce
secteur-là est préoccupant il il a
défrayé la chronique
on va dire il ya une vingtaine d'années
d'une façon assez assez forte et marqué
celle d'hervé c'était moins le cas on a
des problématiques comme partout ni plus
ni moins de stupéfiants et puis
effectivement de d'agressivité puis un
contexte un petit peu de violences
urbaines mais on n'était pas dans
quelque chose d'extrêmement grave et et
qui était sans fin non là les événements
qui sont survenus vendredi dépasse le
cadre même de trappes ces problèmes plus
régionale plus départementale oui on a
on a effectivement sur des départements
voisins et limitrophes et je pas je
pense notamment aux 91
qui effectivement d'une façon récurrente
des faits de cet acabit la voile a
souvent parlé du 93 et je crois qu'il ya
certains départements de la grande
couronne aujourd'hui qui n'ont rien à
envier à la seine saint denis et on a
des faits parfois similaires et avec un
petit peu moins de récurrence mais qui
montre qu'à quand même une violence qui
est ancrée une marche est organisée en
ce moment si vous nous suivez en direct
il est presque 18h15 la marche et qui
vient tout juste de partir attrapez qui
va se diriger jusqu'au square albert
camus où ce jeune a donc trouvé la mort
a été tout simplement assassinés
vous avez un dispositif particulier ce
soir il ya un dispositif particulier
effectivement depuis depuis les faits
c'est à dire qu'il ya des des compagnies
républicaines de sécurité qui se sont
installés à proximité de la ville
il y a aussi et bien des effectifs de la
sécurité publique qui axent davantage
leurs patrouilles sur trappe
le but c'est tout simplement de
maintenir le calme la sérénité
et puis bien évidemment d'éviter une
surenchère qui pourrait conduire à bien
des faits similaires
donc voilà c'est le but c'est ça c'est
maintenir le calme dans la ville les
travers du syndicat de police alliance
nationale vous restez avec nous pour
cette édition spéciale je vous propose à
présent de suivre ce reportage consacré
à moussa à ce jeune qui a donc succombé
à des coups de feu tirés vendredi à
trappes
c'est dans cet établissement attrape que
moussa 14 ans suivait sa scolarité
élèves de 3e consciencieux et
travailleur il laissera le souvenir d'un
garçon sans histoire impliqué dans sa
commune il siégeait également au conseil
municipal des jeunes
c
insupportable c'est inhumain c'est du
barbarisme c'est de la folie une lettre
de faire des choses comme ça voilà je
j'ai vu la famille de moussage retourner
voir à lundi pour voir avec eux comment
on peut les aider à la fois dans la
souffrance mais aussi dans
l'organisation de l'inhumation de de ce
jeune garçon qui est ce jeune trappistes
tué par balle dont le seul tort selon
les premiers éléments de l'enquète
restera de s'être trouvé au mauvais
endroit étaient inscrits auprès de
plusieurs associations avec déclic
théâtre il avait participé au trophée
d'improvisation culture et diversité
voici deux ans ça a été avaient suivi le
championnat inter collèges de saint
quentin en yvelines pendant trois années
donc effectivement on est touché il fait
partie de la famille du match d'impro
donc il ya eu des liens qui se sont
tissés effectivement avec il est
comédien déclic autre témoignage celui
de mustapha larbaoui c'est dans son club
de football que moussa passait son temps
libre le club de football de trappes qui
ce week-end n'a disputé aucune rencontre
en hommage à cet enfant de la ville
règlement de comptes entre quartiers ou
tension plus profonde sur fond de trafic
de drogue les responsables associatifs
et politiques appellent aujourd'hui au
calme et au respect de la mémoire de la
victime et pour la mémoire de la victime
justement une marche blanche se déroule
en ce moment à attraper les partis il y
à quelques instants et sur place
saint-nicolas kirillovitch pour radio
sensations et pour tv fils également
nicolas saillie la marche a été lancé
vous le voyez des armes à la marche
vient de partir plusieurs centaines de
personnes maintenant sont rassemblés et
sont prêtes à marcher jusqu'au quoi ou
square où a lieu les lieux ce drame
vendredi dernier juste quelques
confidences que m'a confié guy malandain
tout à l'heure le maire socialiste de la
ville de trappes il m'a dit je veux
savoir qui sait on qui a fait ça
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas on est dans
la querelle de voisinage je le connais
c'est en parlant évidemment de moussa il
était membre du conseil municipal des
jeunes
c'était un bonheur cet enfant c'est un
garçon comme on aimerait en avoir on
soutien à la famille et il a dit en
conclusion ce n'est pas acceptable la
vie c'est beaucoup des échanges parfois
des querelles
non on ne tue pas vous comprenez ce
message un du maire de la ville entre
fermeté et apaisement est ici c'est
vraiment une ambiance à peser un tout le
monde est là dans le recueillement je
vous le disais beaucoup de roses
blanches et puis j'ai vu aussi d'autres
habitants du 93 qui eux me disait on est
là parce que finalement quel que soit le
quartier quel que soit le département en
banlieue parisienne c'est toujours la
même chose donc une forme de soutien est
une forme de lassitude eux aussi
vis-à-vis d'un drame qui finalement
s'était déjà produit à trappes est qui
et qui n'étonne pas beaucoup de monde
ici
merci nicolas vous interviendrez est
tout au long donc de cette édition
spéciale qui va se poursuivre si vous
nous suivez en direct jusqu'à 19h sur tv
fils et sur radio sensations rco t elle
sur place williams elle pour la
technique édition qui se poursuit nous
allons à présent écouter un autre
témoignage celui de nour el yaqing
louise s'il est responsable du secteur
jeunesse à déclic théâtre l'association
la d'improvisation théâtrale ou a suivi
donc les cours où s'étaient inscrits
moussa des propos accueillis par
catherine château et à patrick jacques
de dixmude de ce que nous n'a pu
connaître
c'est quelqu'un qui nous a laissé
quelque chose de très positif de toute
façon parce que il était déjà assez
discret puis il a arrêté en vérité
l'improvisation il n'est pas allé au
où là il est en troisième il faisait
plus depuis deux ans mais mais en fait
il suivait ses copains et qui eux en
font en font ici à déclic dans l'équipe
junior l'équipe des cadets on pense à
eux aussi parce que ils ont été très
touchés et on sait que ces enfants là
qui sont ses amis eux sont des enfants
très bien des enfants sages des enfants
gentils des enfants entre guillemets
disciplinée qui se mêlent pas aux
problèmes et et puis surtout c'était un
adepte des matchs d'improvisation est
menée à l'école de musique
il ya un groupe là de la plaine de nos
flics avaient l'habitude de venir voir
les spectacles à l'école de musique et
puis et on reconnaît moussa donc on
savait qu'ils étaient là et qui venaient
voir les spectacles le soir des matchs
d'improvisation qu'on peut composter à
la barre on a une responsabilité nous en
tant qu'adulte d'appeler au calme
d'appeler à la sérénité
et puis de rappeler à tout le monde
pilant on était au collège là parce
qu'on a on avait une intervention dans
une classe il y avait des copains à lui
à dire que ben voilà on est avec eux on
est touché et que qu'il faut et qu'il
faut absolument
il faut pas avoir peur voilà de pleurer
de faire parler ses émotions dans un
premier temps et puis et puis pour la
famille de moussa je pense que c'est
important de continuer à montrer qu'on
est content finalement voilà on continue
quoi aujourd'hui on a inscrit un message
qui va aux familles
et à la pensée nous savent sûr sûr sûr
notre sur facebook
cet enfant qui est maurice un super
gosses et comme tous les gosses qu'on
côtoie tant qu'ils sont que des enfants
ils sont innocents et ils sont pour rien
voilà ils sont que victime de deux
voiles adaptée possible injustifiable le
hic travers du syndicat de police
alliance nationale nous accompagne au
cours de cette édition dans un instant
vous réagirez sur les éléments de
l'enquète et puis également sur les
moyens dont vous disposez pour
travailler sur ce secteur en lamé
toujours du côté est des témoignages les
témoignages de soutien qui se sont
multipliées dès le samedi envers nous ça
la population s'est réuni nos équipes
étaient sur place reportage une ambiance
très émouvante beaucoup de visages
fermés des mères de famille des jeunes
venus pour un hommage à vous ça dans la
salle de l'espace anatole-france fermée
à la presse les proches et la famille du
jeune homme rencontré les élus et le
maire
l'objectif préparer la marche
silencieuse de ce lundi
nous avons eu de très nombreuses
questions et toutes toutes les questions
très profonde il faut qu'on arrive ici
comme ça se passe ailleurs également
rançonner pas hélas que qui attrapent
que ceux ci arrivent
il faut qu'on trouve le moyen de faire
casser l'esprit de revanche pour trouver
un esprit des pistes d'explication il
peut pas y avoir de revanche pas y avoir
de haine ne peut pas y avoir
d'assassinât il va ya voir explications
il va y avoir partagé vouloir solidarité
et fraternité
le père du jeune noble et c'est
d'ailleurs appelé au calme
mais parmi la foule rassemblée ce samedi
après midi certains n'hésitent pas à
clamer leur colère pour le manque de
moyens est au centre de ce problème
certes hommage à moussa condé renonce à
toute sa famille mais on est avec eux
tous les jours c'est pas aujourd'hui il
faut se réveiller oui on avec eux on
réfléchit à eux c'est trop tard ça va
pas faire ramer mousse à l'aller ce qui
arrive là c'est personne ne peut
l'accepter parce qu'ils étaient des
jeunes d'autres quartiers on sait pas
qui a tiré des venir hors du quartier de
tirer comme ça sur les gens comme ça sur
des innocents sur des enfants comme ça
c'est insupportable
on demande que l'état de
fait la justice il faut qu'on trouve
celui qui a tiré et leur demandent
justice parce qu'on ne peut pas rester
on est vraiment sur l'échappée ne sera
retirée avant de donner albert camus les
abandonner donc il n'y a pas de gardien
il n'y a pas des gens qui peuvent
prendre à attention et voir les jeunes
qu'est ce qu'ils veulent c'est vrai
qu'il faut quand même qu'on se demande
un moment qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour que ça ne se reproduise
pas voilà et le nécessaire en termes de
sécurité attrape n'ai pas fait ça c'est
une réalité n'appartient pas simplement
mer j'ai interpellé aussi de ministre de
l'intérieur
parce qu'on à chaque fois des promesses
en terme d'effectifs de police de
manière pérenne des accusations que
réfute la mairie qui estime que tout est
fait dans le quartier sur la prévention
nous nous avons une mission un organisme
qui s'appelle la sauvegarde qui est
chargé de la mission d'éducation de
prévention et auprès des jeunes nous
avons la maison des parents
nous avons les structures
socio-éducatives comme celle où on était
là tout à l'heure qui reçoivent les
jeunes quand ils ont besoin bref toute
une série de structures comme ça mais ça
ne suffit jamais l'heure est en tout cas
au recueillement avant la marche
silencieuse de ce lundi soir au jeu
tout ça c'est de joie à couper
il a toujours en plateau l'oeil travers
du syndicat de police alliance nationale
on entendu dans ce reportage quelques
éléments plus polémique et notamment le
fait que ces quartiers là est un petit
peu à l'abandon est ce que c'est votre
sentiment aussi on l'a déjà dénoncé à
plusieurs reprises des éléments enfin
récents nous permettent effectivement
d'affirmer ça tout simplement parce que
trap est une aide sp donc une zone de
sécurité prioritaire qu'il y a une il y
avait il ya quelques temps la création
et c'est d'ailleurs en cours encore
d'une communauté d'agglomération
regroupant d'un point de vue secteur
police guyancourt et l'encours et rap
la problématique et nous l'avions
dénoncé à l'époque c'est que tout ça ça
s'est fait avec sans moyens
supplémentaires
un nid de moyens humains supplémentaires
ni d'argent supplémentaire donc c'est un
vrai problème de ce point de vue là on a
vu que les éléments du iliad il ya des
événements en début d'année notamment la
sphère de charlie hebdo qui a permis de
prendre conscience effectivement que les
services de renseignement devait être
renforcée ce qui est fait c'est très
bien par contre il ne faut pas que ça se
fasse au détriment et bien de la
surveillance générale et quelque part
des effectifs de la sécurité publique
qui a eu pour l'instant voient leurs
effectifs baisser et plus
particulièrement d'une façon générale
sur le 60 18 depuis cinq ans on ne
compte plus en dizaines en étant
centaine essais des notices et la
sélection de véritablement aujourd'hui
il faut il faut être inquiet par rapport
aux moyens dont vous disposez par
rapport aux faits tels que celui qui est
survenu vendredi c'est des choses qui me
sens désolé mais qu'il pourrait se
reproduire tout simplement parce que
vous ne disposez pas de moyens sur le
terrain c'est clair ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui sur trappe et d'une façon
générale dans la police et nous nous ce
sont deux demandé de l'appeler
mais façon très forte c'est
l'instauration d'un vrai plan marshall
pour la sécurité ça paraît fort comeau
c'est plein de sens mais la réalité elle
est là c'est qu'ici on veut des moyens
effectivement humains en plus avec suivi
de moyens financiers tout simplement par
exemple des fois l'attribution de
véhicules en nombre tout simplement pour
faire la mission de base qui est la
sécurité générale et est bien évidemment
à travers sa respecter la la la la
vision de la prévention avant de faire
quoi que ce soit de répressif mais il
faut qu'il y ait quelque chose faut
qu'il y ait quelque chose qui déclenche
sinon on va pas y arriver mais ça veut
dire quel policier aujourd'hui auront
peur aussi d'intervenir sur le terrain
parce qu'ils ne disposent pas dispose
pas de moyens pardon parce qu'ils ne
sont pas assez nombreux parce que non il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas de peur pour
l'intervention des policiers à chaque
fois que les policiers ont utilisé n'y a
pas de zone de non et encore non il n'y
a pas de zone de non droit la même si on
a des difficultés parfois dans pour
aller dans certains endroits où quand on
y va on y va
eh bien on va dire en force et avec des
moyens supplémentaires il est évident
que dans certains endroits on va éviter
que des deux collègues tendus dans une
voiture sérigraphiée yahi seul bien
évidemment c'est à dire qu à ce moment
là bas il ya des dispositifs qui se met
en place avec des renforts etc
il n'y a pas d'endroit qui sont où
personne ne va où les policiers ne vont
pas où il ya des difficultés
oui on a entendu un appel au calme de la
part des parents des deux victimes du
jeune décédé et puis également du jeune
blessé à la jambe
on a entendu aussi les politiques qui
appelait au calme surtout pas de
vengeance de représailles ça aussi c'est
une crainte que vous avez aujourd'hui ce
qui a des consignes particulières qu'on
était passés auprès des différents
services pour surveiller un petit peu
l'évolution de la situation dans les
prochains jours prochaines heures bah
effectivement le but je crois que tous
les gens qui appellent au calme ont
raison c'est c'est le bon sens et la
police ces vertus justement en ce moment
à travers un dispositif un petit peu
renforcé avec la présence des compagnies
républicaines de sécurité
et puis de nombreuses patrouilles qui
sont davantage axés sur trappe par
rapport à l'accoutumée le but c'est ça
c'est de maintenir la sérénité de faire
en sorte qu'ils aient pas de surenchère
qui ait pas de vengeance comme vous le
disiez ça c'est ça c'est primordial si
on veut effectivement maintenir le calme
dans la ville
il est presque 18h30 si vous nous suivez
en direct sur terrifié soixante dix huit
éditions spéciales donc du journal le
journal qui va se poursuivre au delà de
son horaire habituel vous retrouverez à
vos émissions du lundi soir le 7-8 sport
notamment aux alentours de 19 heures
pour la première diffusion nous revenons
et sur les événements qui ont secoué la
trappe et pas seulement même au delà
événements et qui secoue la classe
politique qui secoue la population cet
assassinat d'un jeune de 14 ans a juste
en bas de son immeuble
aujourd'hui je reviens juste sur l'
enquête qu'on a évoqué au tout début de
cette édition
aujourd'hui le risque aussi c'est
peut-être la loi du silence est-ce que
vous avez j'imagine que les enquêteurs
effectivement
vont peut-être être confronté à sa 7 mai
retard c'est comme ça qu'on peut le dire
j'espère que ce sera pas le cas j'espère
que effectivement les témoignages seront
intéressants et c'est peut-être là
effectivement la clé du succès de
l'enquète c'est-à-dire qu'elle quelque
part une enquête efficace sur les
constatations sur tout un tas de choses
mais aussi quelque part une
collaboration delà de la delà de la
population mais pour tenter d'arrêter
ses assassins et c'est criminel
cette édition spéciale du journal de la
rédaction se poursuit sur téléphiles en
simultané sur ado sensations alors que
se déroule en ce moment à trappes une
marche blanche contre la violence et en
mémoire du jeune trappistes décédé
vendredi
nous allons repartir sur le terrain dans
un instant où se trouvent nos équipes
annoncées malgré tout avant les
événements de ce week end le déplacement
ce lundi matin du président socialiste
de la région ile-de-france à trappes a
été maintenu un déplacement pour jean
paul huchon qui s'inscrivait dans le
cadre de sa candidature à un nouveau
mandat en décembre prochain qui a
forcément pris en tournant particulier
reportage
le lycée de la plaine de neauphle
attrape un établissement à quelques
minutes seulement du square albert camus
théâtre de la fusillade qui a coûté la
vie à un jeune de 14 ans le déplacement
du président de région socialiste jean
paul huchon ce lundi matin bien
qu'annoncé la semaine dernière a donc
pris une tournure différente si les
questions d'éducation et de moyens ont
été abordés dans toutes les têtes et sur
toutes les lèvres
le prénom moussa s'est imposé j'étais
révoltée pour ma part de de ce complice
comme ça tire et arrosé
dans le sens aucune véritable raison
un des histoires de peut-être peut-être
on n'en sait rien encore mais de bandes
ou d'autres choses
quand un jeune qui semble-t-il avait
vraiment que des amis beaucoup de
qualités ça a été reconnu par le maire
je les entends d'une avant-hier
disparaît comme ça ça ça laisse une
trace indélébile et nous devons tout
faire pour sécuriser nos établissements
et jean paul huchon de rappeler le
travail nécessaire de médiation entre
les quartiers l'importance du rôle tenu
par les associations dans les
établissements scolaires et en dehors
le dialogue ne doit jamais être rompu
pour le président de région après
charlie par exemple il a fallu beaucoup
palais on a fait une vingtaine
d'établissements au total pour parler
avec les jeunes pour comprendre comment
il avait ressenti tout ça et c'est
parfois d'ailleurs un peu un peu
inquiétant parce qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément tout compris
comme les choses se sont passées mais
c'est important d'aller au contact et de
discuter et lui attrape député de la
circonscription benoît hamon était
présent lors de ce déplacement il a
également tenu à condamner et à rassurer
c'est anormal qu'on meurt en bas de chez
soi de balles d'armes automatiques
aujourd'hui en france que ce soit à
trappes n'importe où ailleurs et dans
une ville où
paradoxalement la délinquance recule ou
la qualité de vie s'améliore même si les
difficultés sociales restent même si les
tensions existent entre quartiers même
s'il ya aussi de trafic de stupéfiants
s'est pas c'est pas ça qui domine
attrape la ltc qu'on y vit normalement
tous les jours et en marge de ce
déplacement on notera également une
autre réaction politique celle de
valérie pécresse candidate aux
régionales sur les réseaux sociaux elle
s'est dite choquée et préoccupé par la
banalisation de l'usagé d'armes
elle sera en déplacement dans les
yvelines mercredi et jeudi et sur place
à trappes poursuivre cette marche
organisée en ce moment depuis à 18h et
nicolas kirillovitch saint-nicolas vous
êtes sur place avec que william l
nicolas nicolas si vous m'entendez ouais
nicolas vous êtes à l'antenne c'est un
boulot et vous êtes avec une des
personnes qui participent au
rassemblement la manifestation
exactement une personne qui encadrent
ici le rassemblement lors vous le voyez
qui vous allez le voir bientôt mais le
rassemblement est maintenant parti avec
évidemment tous les hommes politiques à
valérie pécresse jean michel fourgous
benoît hamon en tête du cortège et la
famille moussa et puis une jeune
personne en cadence en cas d'autre ici
du de la marche vous êtes excusé moi
déjà je travaille pour la mairie trapel
muna édith ou un peu quelle est la
démarche de cette marche et quel est le
but d'une telle marche aujourd'hui
joindre hommage à la famille parce que
parce que c'est très difficile pour eux
et du coup on va se et du coup voilà on
est on est tous réunis pour rendre
hommage parce que c'est vraiment
important
six vols importants et on soutient la
famille à 100% quoi et j'ai le projet
d'un panneau c'est peu le message
aujourd'hui qu'on veut faire passer
principalement pas d'arrêter la guerre
surtout arrêtez la guerre
et voilà et on aimerait que cette guerre
soit finie parce que ces dommages là on
en vient à a tué un gosse a retiré
l'avis d'un gosse donc voilà on aimerait
que ça s'arrête et puis et qq et que
justice soit faite
vous parlez de guerre carrément pour
vous c'est seulement qu'il faut employer
enfin guerre parce que
on en vient à un enfant mort quoi si
c'est pas une guerre c'est quoi dix mois
on voit l'amour lui donc on soutient la
famille à 100% et j'ai même pas de nous
parce que voilà et on est très content
d'avoir de voir tout ce monde là qui
soutient la famille et on continue à
soutenir
on continue à soutenir et qui repose
antenne ça et il restera gravé dans nos
mémoires
merci vous voyez wilfried aller les
mêmes mots toujours employé ici
ces mots de pays de rassemblement vous
êtes en train de voir derrière moi que
le rassemblement qui passe le cortège
justement qui passe à l'instant avec la
famille moussa les proches de moussa et
puis l'ensemble de la classe politique
là vous êtes vraiment au coeur du
rassemblement la population qui a du mal
aussi un petit peu à s'exprimer qui
préfèrent garder le silence aussi un
moment de communion un petit peu il est
difficile de recueillir aussi des
témoignages dans cette manifestation
oui exactement la plupart des gens ici
disent que finalement il n'y a pas grand
chose à dire à part se recueillir dans
le silence l'ambiance est très calme ici
pas le pas de mouvement particulier tout
le monde tout le monde réfléchit tout le
monde pense aux conséquences au pourquoi
de ce drame
et finalement tout le monde dit
l'ensemble des jeunes ici je leur ai
demandé ce que vous voulez intervenir
ils m'ont dit vous voulez qu'on dise
quoi finalement et c'est ça vraiment
l'état d'esprit de cette marche
merci nicolas on vous retrouvera tout à
l'heure encore pour faire un point sur
la mobilisation revient sur le nombre de
participants malgré la pluie 1 malgré
les conditions climatiques l'émotion et
est telle que les gens ont fait le
déplacement participent vous avez vu et
ces quelques images du cortège il y à
quelques instants et nous y reviendrons
bien sûr dans nos prochaines éditions
sûreté défilent avec des reportages
complets dès demain d'ores et déjà
rendez-vous et des aides 18h aux
quelques réactions pour poursuivre de
personnalité et qui elles ne sont pas
présentes sur cette marche mais qui se
sont exprimés rapidement sur les réseaux
sociaux à jamel debbouze qui apporte son
soutien à la famille et aux trappistes
il évoque une injustice
omar sy actuellement à l'étranger en
italie il tourne son prochain film avec
tom hanks il adresse ses prières à
moussa paix à moussa épais attrapé puis
le rappeur également la fouine qui est
lui aussi a grandi dans cette ville des
yvelines qui se dit très touchée
extrêmement triste édition spéciale je
vous le disais sûreté les filets radio
sensations en direct entre 18 et 19
heures je propose de vous rendre de nous
rendre pardon à nouveau au collège
gustave courbet ou le jeune moussa a été
scolarisé
mais sans histoire apprécié de ses
camarades de la rentrée ce matin après
les vacances scolaires s'est déroulée
dans la souffrance mélanie poker lionel
torrès rentrée plus que difficile ce
matin pour les élèves et les équipes
pédagogiques de l'établissement du staff
courbes et attrapes
c'est dans ces murs que moussa a étudié
dans les classes pour sa classe le
risque de doubler la journée et prévenir
les élèves qu'il y avait donc des
cellules des poutres mis à leur
disposition
de par leur triste par les infirmières
assistantes sociales les médecins
scolaires sont actuellement auprès des
enfants les plus touchés pour les cours
une minute de silence a été organisée
dans la cour de l'établissement ce matin
au moment de la récréation des dessins
et des textes ont été réalisés par ceux
qui le souhaitaient ses productions
seront remises à la famille de moussa et
après l'émotion c'est la justice qui va
devoir faire son travail loïc travers
donc responsable secrétaire zonal
adjoint du syndicat alliance police
nationale aujourd'hui si on peut refaire
un point sur sur cette enquête
où en est-on aujourd'hui bah en fait
l'idée c'est qu'on fait suite au tout à
toutes les constatations qui sont
déroulés le jour du crime
c'est à dire que là on rentre dans une
phase assez longues ou les enquêteurs et
bien vont exploiter les constatations
qu'ils ont réalisé ils vont tenter
d'obtenir le maximum de témoignages sans
s'intéresser à l'entourage les amis la
famille etc
le voisinage est le but va être
effectivement d'effectuer des
recoupements des regroupements
judiciaire pour tenter de
d'établir un mobile qui pourra peut-être
guidé les enquêteurs vers vers un groupe
de personnes ouvert vers une personne en
particulier
pour l'instant il n'y a ni mobile n'est
suspect pour l'instant il est trop tôt
effectivement de parler d'un suspect ou
deux plusieurs suspects et même chose
pour le mobile on ne le connaît pas des
faits d'une telle ampleur d'une telle
gravité c'est aussi inédit sur ce
secteur comme trappe sur le secteur de
trappes ces derniers temps c'est plutôt
inédit effectivement il y a eu des
accrochages et il ya eu des des coups de
feu il ya quelques temps mais pas de
cette intensité là il faut rappeler
qu'on est face à des gens qui ont
utilisé une arme automatique qui ont
tiré en rafales du 9 mm donc à plusieurs
reprises dans un endroit habité on peut
noter une certaine rapidité dans
l'action avec ce véhicule sans doute un
conducteur et un tireur donc ça veut
dire qu'il ya quelque chose d'organisé
et qui ressemble pas vraiment en terme
d'intensité en termes d'impact à tout ce
qui a pu être vécue et bien évidemment
si ce jeu la finalité tragique c'est à
dire qu'il ya quand même un blessés et
un mort
quand vous dites c'est quelque chose qui
semble organisé et qui était prévu il
n'y avait pas moyen de prévenir
justement là d'anticiper de déjouer ce
genre d'événement vous l'avez évoqué il
ya eu quelques coups de feu il ya eu
quelques tensions assez fortes assez
vives ces dernières semaines sur ce
secteur de trappes
bah oui tout à fait oui après le prévoir
c'est compliqué parce que à partir du
moment où effectivement on a une action
isolée comme celle-ci qu'a priori elles
n'étaient pas dire ça s'est pas produit
10 fois d'affilée sur les trois derniers
mois
donc ça veut dire que il ya un calme
apparent malgré tout il ya quelques
soucis il ya effectivement certains le
rappelait tout à l'heure à des problèmes
liés
des phénomènes de bandes de stupéfiants
effectivement mais pas plus qu'ailleurs
dans les yvelines la nécessité pas de
mettre plus de moyens
ces dernières semaines ces derniers
jours sur trappe avant que n'arrive
cette tragédie ainsi d'une façon
générale puisque je rappelle que trap
est une zone de sécurité prioritaires
une zsp et donc à ce titre d'ailleurs
notre syndicat alliance police nationale
avant défendu l'idée qu'il fallait il
mettre davantage de moyens et qu'il ne
fallait surtout pas rester à effectif
constant
alors même que l'on avait un dispositif
particulier qui se mettait en place
donc il ya eu un effet d annonce
malheureusement qui n'a pas été suivi
sur le terrain en tout cas d'un point de
vue de l'équipement de des policiers
aujourd'hui avec votre syndicat
justement vous allez surveiller les
moyens qui vont être déployés au delà du
fait de résoudre cette enquête mais
aussi sur le long terme
vous demandez aujourd'hui toujours plus
de moyens sont un acteur on a on a un
ministère qui il ya quelques il ya
quelques jours s'est vu rallonger son
budget de plusieurs millions d'euros
on aimerait bien que ça arrive aussi au
ministère de l'intérieur
je disais tout à l'heure effectivement
que l'idée d'alliances et de demander et
en tout cas de faire en sorte que
l'instauration d'un d'un plan marshall
de la sécurité donc le but c'est quoi
c'est d'avoir tout simplement des moyens
humains donc important et avec ses
moyens humains et bien la suite logique
c'est à dire financière et
les moyens matériels qui vont avec ça
pas ceux d'un gilet pare-balles par et
bien les armes les cartouches les moyens
tout simplement tels que le taser et c
c'est à dire tout ce qui équipe et qui
permet aux policiers d'effectuer une
mission de surveillance efficace tous
les jours sur le terrain justement pour
travailler tous les jours j'aimerais
savoir quel est le climat actuellement
est ce que vous y aller sereinement est
ce que la population collabore aussi
bien vous donner des éléments qui vous
permettent de résoudre déjà cette
affaire et puis également les
différentes tensions parce que on évoque
des trafics de stupéfiants sur ces zones
là et au delà du décès de ce jeune il va
falloir aussi restaurer un petit peu le
calme et la tranquillité pour tous les
habitants du quartier aujourd'hui quel
est le climat aujourd'hui le but
effectivement c'est de maintenir le
calme ça semble être le cas pour
l'instant
il faut espérer effectivement à la fois
pour la population mais aussi pour les
policiers que ça le soit le plus
longtemps possible
après des faits comme ça le risque c'est
d'avoir une situation effectivement
d'appels à la vengeance ou de surenchère
il faut à tout prix éviter ça et là ce
n'est effectivement que on va dire une
présence policière sur le terrain
dissuasive qui ne peut que ramener le
calme ou en tout cas le maintenir ça
c'est le but c'est à dire pour ça que la
direction départementale a déployé un
dispositif adapté avec des compagnies
républicaines de sécurité
et puis des patrouilles de sécurité
publique qui sont axées davantage sur
trappe et ces secteurs notamment
aujourd'hui alors que se déroulaient
actuellement si vous nous suivez en
direct
il est 18h 18h40 la manifestation la
marche blanche qui est organisé et un
dispositif spécifique aujourd'hui pour
ne serait ce qu'à l'issue de la
mobilisation de la population et éviter
tout débordement même si tout se passe
dans le calme on l'a vu aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr il ya un dispositif qui est
encore une fois adapté si c'est le même
c'est le mot plus ou moins discrets
effectivement pour pas faire en sorte
que l'on nous taxent de 2,2 de faire de
l'argent pour acheter les portions voilà
sont pas le but c'est ça c'est de calmer
et ne surtout pas faire en sorte qu'ils
aient de surenchère merci l'oeil travers
du syndicat de police alliance on est
revenu sur ce plateau nous avons
accompagné ce soir avant de repartir sur
trappe en direct au milieu d'eux des
différentes personnes qui sont
mobilisées vous en voyez d'ailleurs
quelques images de cette mobilisation
il ya plus de 400 500 personnes nous
ferons un point plus précis
dans quelques instants je vous propose
pour l'instant de revoir ce reportage
consacré à moussa cette jeune victime
ses proches parlent d'un jeune sans
histoire c'est dans cet établissement
attrape que moussa 14 ans suivait sa
scolarité élèves de 3e consciencieux et
travailleur il laissera le souvenir d'un
garçon sans histoire impliqué dans sa
commune il siège également au conseil
municipal des jeunes c'est insupportable
c'est inhumain c'est du barbarisme c'est
de la folie complète de de faire des
choses comme ça voilà je vu la famille
de moussa jo tournée voir lundi pour
voir avec eux comment on peut les aider
à la fois dans la souffrance mais aussi
dans l'organisation de l'inhumation de
de ce genre sont conviés tous et ce
jeune trappistes tué par balle dont le
seul tort selon les premiers éléments de
l'enquète restera de s'être trouvé au
mauvais endroit étaient inscrits auprès
de plusieurs associations avec déclic
théâtre il avait participé au trophée
d'improvisation culture et diversité
voici deux ans ça a été avait suivi le
championnat inter collèges de saint
quentin en yvelines pendant trois années
donc effectivement on est touché il fait
partie de la famille du match d'impro
donc il ya eu des liens qui se sont
tissés effectivement avec il est comme
été un déclic
autre témoignage celui de mustapha
larbaoui c'est dans son club de football
que moussa passait son temps libre le
club de football de trappes qui ce
week-end n'a disputé aucune rencontre en
hommage à cet enfant de la ville
règlement de comptes entre quartiers ou
tension plus profonde sur fond de trafic
de drogue les responsables associatifs
et politiques appellent aujourd'hui au
calme et au respect de la mémoire de la
victime
nous retournons donc en direct à trappes
retrouver à nicolas kirillovitch
pauvreté les filets radio sensations
vous êtes avec eux william l
et vous avez un nouveau témoignage à
nous livrer exactement à mes côtés et
esther lafitte qui était candidate sur
trappe pour les pour les cantonales pour
les départementales mais également
coresponsable du groupe europe écologie
les verts pour saint quentin en yvelines
et serre la vis tu dites nous quel est
le message que vous voulez faire passer
en tant que femme politique quand vous
venez une telle ou telle marche était le
recueillement je voulais témoigner ma
solidarité à cette famille qui a perdu
un enfant et je trouve que c'est des
événements dramatiques qui qui doit
interpeller tout le monde est en fait je
n'ai pas de réponse a à dire qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire mais en tout cas tous
ces gens qui sont venus ils ont envie
que ça ne se reproduise pas et compte
qu'on puisse peut-être être ensemble
autrement que dans le deuil
ça serait bien aussi parce que là ça
fait la deuxième marche après celui de
janvier que j'ai fait à paris dans cet
esprit là et c'est c'est assez triste
nicolas je tenais à être là c'est
important nicolas simon lui responsables
politiques finalement nicolas oui si
vous m'entendez peut-être justement vous
écoute lui demander en tant qu' en tant
que politiques responsables politiques
si elle a le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui
elle les moyens existent sur le terrain
on l'a évoqué depuis le début de cette
édition est quelquefois certains
évoquent le manque de moyens
véritablement mis en place pour prévenir
ce genre de situations dramatiques
est ce que vous estimez vous qu'en tant
que responsable politique aujourd'hui
une ville comme sera pas les moyens pour
éviter de nouveaux drames dans le futur
est actuellement également baisse qui va
s qui donnait moyens ça je ne sais pas
exactement mais en tout cas c'est sûr
qu'il faut mettre plus de présence plus
de et plus de concertation dans les
quartiers parce que
il ya certainement quelque chose qui va
pas donc il faut peut-être demander aux
gens aussi ce qu'ils aimeraient faire
eux c'est à dire que c'est peut-être pas
seulement d'amérique des lapins réponse
doit venir mais mais justement il faut
qu'ils écoutent peut-être plus les gens
et mais il faut qu'ils mettent aussi
plus de moyens pour vous la réponse est
donc on va dire civile mais également le
politique elle n'est pas uniquement
politique je pense que ça d'avenir de la
société aussi et écouter ce que les gens
peuvent penser d'une solution ensemble
voilà vous de freed scénariste à la
fuite mais sa responsable du groupe
europe ecologie les verts de saint
quentin en yvelines
merci nicolas on vous retrouvera une
dernière fois dans quelques minutes pour
refaire un point sur cette mobilisation
aujourd'hui ce soir à trappes après elle
s'est fait à dramatique qui sont
survenus vendredi après midi dans la
commune aurait coûté à présent un autre
témoignage est celui de nouvelles yakine
luis responsable du secteur jeunesse de
déclic théâtre l'association
d'improvisation de trappes où était
inscrit le jeune moussa décédé vendredi
les propos ont été recueillis par
catherine du gâteau et les patrick
jacques de dixmude de ce que nous on a
pu connaître
c'est quelqu'un qui nous a laissé
quelque chose de très positif de toute
façon parce que il était déjà assez
discret et puis il a arrêté en vérité
l'improvisation il n'est pas allé au
bout
il était en troisième il faisait plus
depuis deux ans mais mais en fait il
suivait ses copains et qui eux en font
en font ici à déclic dans l'équipe
junior l'équipe des cadets on pense à
eux aussi parce que ils ont été très
touchés et on sait que ces enfants là
qui sont ses amis eux sont des enfants
très bien des enfants sages des enfants
gentils des enfants entre guillemets
discipline et qui se met pas au problème
et puis surtout
c'était un adepte des matchs
d'improvisation ils venaient à l'école
de musique il ya eu un groupe là de la
plaine de neauphle qu'avait l'habitude
de venir voir les spectacles à l'école
de musique et puis et on reconnaît
moussa donc on savait qu'ils étaient là
et qui venaient voir les spectacles le
soir des matchs d'improvisation qu'on
peut qu'on peut faire là bas on a une
responsabilité nous en tant qu'adulte
d'appeler au calme d'appeler à la
sérénité
et puis de rappeler à tout le monde puis
là on était au collège là parce qu'on a
on avait une intervention dans une
classe il y avait des copains à lui à
dire que ben voilà on est avec eux qu'
on est touché et que qu'il faut et qu'il
faut absolument
il faut pas avoir peur voilà de pleurer
de faire parler ses émotions dans un
premier temps et qui et puis pour la
famille de moussa je pense que c'est
important de continuer à montrer qu'on
est content finalement voilà on continue
quoi aujourd'hui on a inscrit un message
qui va aux familles
la pensée nous savent sûr sûr sûr notre
sur notre facebook
cet enfant qui est mort il c'est un
super gosses et comme tous les gosses
qu'on côtoie tant qu'ils sont que des
enfants ils sont innocents et et ils
sont pour rien voilà ils sont que
victime de deux voiles adapté
compréhensible injustifiable quelques
règles sur la présence de personnalités
liées à cette ville de trappes la
réaction de jamel debbouze qui apporte
son soutien via les réseaux sociaux à la
famille aux trappistes il évoque une
injustice omar sy actuellement à
l'étranger en italie pour un tournage
adresse ses prières à moussa pea moussa
épais attrapé puis le rappeur à la
fouine qui lui aussi a grandi dans cette
ville des yvelines se dit très touchée
est extrêmement triste
si vous venez nous rejoindre édition
spéciale sur tv fil 78 diffusée
également sur radio sensations après les
événements qui sont survenus vendredi
sur la commune de trappes le rappel des
faits à présent que s'est il déroulé
vendredi après midi vendredi
le 1er mai le reportage de la rédaction
vendredi 1er mai entre 15h15 et 15h30
une voiture surgit dans le square albert
camus attrape des individus cagoulés
sortent d'une voiture renault et tire
sur un groupe de jeunes avec une arme
automatique 9 mm quatorze douilles
seront retrouvées sur place
moussa 14 ans est abattu un autre jeune
de 17 ans légèrement blessé à la jambe
est emmené dans un hôpital des yvelines
une escalade de la violence alors que la
ville connaissait depuis quelques
semaines des rixes entre différents
squares trap est une est une ville qui
est plutôt qui s'est beaucoup calmé
depuis plusieurs années puisque mis à
part les événements qui a eu lieu au
mois de juillet 2013
les violences urbaines ont
considérablement baissé
mais c'est vrai que paradoxalement les
trafics de stupéfiants
le cannabis entre autres gêné enfin les
trafiquants n'ont aucun intérêt à ce que
les services de police vienne vienne
enquêter et et se gêner leur gêne et
gênait c'était cette économie
souterraine
la voiture des fuyards a été retrouvé
calciné à ben les enquêteurs n'écartent
aucune piste guerre de territoire x deux
bandes rivales sur fond de trafic de
stupéfiants
l'enquète s'annonce difficile une marche
est organisée en ce moment attrapant en
mémoire de ce jeune également de l'autre
victime blessée légèrement à la jambe
qui était âgée de 17 ans la marche qui
s'est élancé il y à peu près trois
quarts d'heure et nicolas on les voit
les mails et les personnes mobilisées
qui défilent derrière vous oui
exactement vous voyez là la foule qui
passe derrière moi on voit également je
sais pas si vous pouvez bien le voir des
banderoles avec le par exemple ces deux
banderoles importés par certains
collégiens où il était inscrit hommage à
moussa tu n'es pas partie on va
resserrer les liens petit soldat tu
resteras dans nos coeurs je sais pas si
vous l'avez vu également mais tous les
hommes politiques jean michel fourgous
valérie pécresse benoît hamon viennent
de passer derrière nous la famine moussa
vous voyez beaucoup de jeunes toujours
dans cette ambiance de recueillement de
respect envers la famille encore une
fois j'ai essayé d'intercepter quelqu'un
et qui m'a dit vous savez on n'a pas
grand chose à dire dans ce moment là
toujours le même état d'esprit
recueillement et on avance
tranquillement jusqu'au square où albert
camus où s'est déroulé le drame vendredi
où le petit moussa a été tué vendredi
dernier et les fleurs seront déposées à
l'issue de la mobilisation et de la
marche 1 c'est bien ça pour la suite
la suite de ce mois je vous ai pas
souvent entendu wilfried des fleurs
seront déposées comme on doit se
terminer il n'y aura pas de prise de
parole vous parler de ce silence de ce
respect de la part des personnes
mobilisées mais les politiques aussi
n'ont pas prévu de s'exprimer
non pour l'instant officiellement
personne n'a prévu de parler
recueillement total que ce soit de la
part de guy malandain ou des autres élus
et comme vous disiez des gerbes doivent
être
déposé il y a d'ailleurs je vous l'avais
dit en début d'émission beaucoup ici
beaucoup de roses ont été distribuées
des roses blanches
tout le monde ici comme vous dit vous
voyez peut-être m'aider santé de même
voir des milliers de personnes et sont
réunis ici à trappes avec des roses
blanches et toujours ce sentiment de
recueillement jusqu'à la fin de la
marche
albert camus donc merci nicolas keilwitz
pour radio sensations et pour téléphiles
également accompagnés de william elle
pour ces points réguliers depuis 18h sur
cette marche qui est organisée à trappes
nous allons refermer cette édition
spéciale du journal de téléphiles que
vous avez suivi également sur le 98 4
une édition consacrée à cette fusillade
qui a coûté la vie à un jeune trappistes
de 14 ans vendredi après-midi la marche
va se poursuivre
reportage complet dans notre édition de
demain à 18 heures du journal les
programmes qui se poursuivent à présent
sur tv fils à demain